da würde ich gerne frau wiedl friedel
weyrauch einmal bitten sie arbeitet seit
23 jahren ehrenamtlich für das deutsche
rote kreuz für das sorgentelefon für
angehörige von menschen mit
suchtproblemen und auch dort sind die
anrufe massiv gestiegen
frau weihrauch in welche frage haben sie
denn an die bundeskanzlerin
bitte das mikrofon einschalten herz gut
da ja schön ja danke dass ich mich doch
drangenommen london jeder dran also
notfalls kläger hat noch drei minuten
drauf sehr ich liebe fernsehen wo die
sendung dann zu ende ist also in letzter
zeit bekommt ja verstärkt anrufe von
angehörigen wo sich zu hause die
situation zuspitzt
und weil die wohnung ist zu eng die
kinder sind zu hause lernen ihn jetzt in
der in der kinderzeit und home office
und dann drehte vater durch und geht 1
trinken und dann eskaliert und oft ist
es so dass ich dann da stehe und
versucht jemand ins frauenhaus zu
vermitteln
aber es geht nicht so voll sind hotels
zu dann habe ich versucht infektionen zu
kommen und das hat mal geklappt aber oft
stehe ich dann da und ich nehme das
jedes mal mit
ich bin genauso verzweifelt ich würde
gerne den arm nehmen die betroffenen
aber das geht ja nett und das alles so
am telefon ab zu mit den leuten zu
besprechen so kalte atmosphäre und ja
also ich denke immer ich mist ich bin
froh wenn wenn wieder normale zustände
sind dass man wieder die gruppen auf
machen kann und das war ein zusätzliches
handicap oder fährt sie betroffenen und
auch die angehörigen haben ihre gruppen
die können sich da aus weinen und werden
unterstützt verbal und das ist was ganz
anderes und die waren oft so verzweifelt
und da die richtigen worte zu finden
oder überhaupt ersatz dafür zu
beschaffen
dass sie gibt das sie getröstet werden
und das dass der papa in therapie gehen
kann und aber da ich ja auch die grenzen
im moment also das ist schon eine
situation am telefon und die ju anrufe
verstärken sich also das war ja gedacht
nur am wochenende und mittlerweile
klingt es jeden tag und ich trinke nicht
fertig nicht dran zu gehen
das ist das ist gut aber es fordert sie
wahrscheinlich auch unglaublich nicht
manchmal könnte ich an die wand werfen
sich telefon nicht auch sie noch haben
sie ein paar mitstreiter die mit denen
sie sind mit denen sie sich da mal die
telefone zu schmeißen können aber das
wäre meine bitte dass man vielleicht ein
bisschen das öffentlich gemacht weil sie
sich so schwierig ehrenamtliche im
moment zu finden oder überhaupt zu
finden
die da spaß dran haben das macht ja auch
man kriegt ja auch was zurück von den
menschen die am telefon ziehen also ich
bin oft froh oder meistens froh wenn ich
das den hörer auflegt wusste ich das war
gut dass du dran war
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren